in this country the january 6 committee
may be considering another high-profile
subpoena this time for jenny thomas a
conservative activist and the wife of
supreme court justice clarence thomas
she was in direct contact with members
of former president trump's inner circle
and with others who were seeking to
overturn the 2020 election results
nicole killian is on capitol hill nicole
good morning
good morning to you nate the committee
is engaged with jenny thomas's counselor
her lawyer did not respond to requests
for comment from cbs news but has
previously expressed serious concerns
about her sitting for an interview
it's very important for us to speak with
her vice chair liz chaney warned the
january six elect committee could
consider a subpoena against jenny thomas
if the well-known conservative activist
doesn't come forward i hope she will
agree to do so voluntarily but i'm sure
we will contemplate a subpoena if she
won't the committee sent a letter in
june requesting her appearance after
learning she exchanged messages with
former white house chief of staff mark
meadows and attorney john eastman who
authored a memo about how to block
certification of the 2020 election
results whether it involves the wife of
a supreme court justice or anyone else
if they have information or a role an
effort to return election yes they're
not excluded from examination friday
former trump political adviser steve
bannon was convicted on two counts of
contempt of congress for defying a
committee subpoena and could face up to
two years in jail but you can't ignore a
congressional subpoena or you'll pay the
price the panel says it has not decided
on a criminal referral to the justice
department against the former president
but urged it not to wait i sure as hell
hope they have a criminal investigation
at this point into donald trump and
emboldened trump lashed out in a pair of
weekend rallies if i announced that i
was not going to run for office
the persecution
of donald trump would immediately stop
the former president will be in
washington for a speech tomorrow it will
be his first time back since he left
office in january 2021 but his former
vice president mike pence may be looking
to steal some of his thunder with his
own speech here in town tonight gail
there does seem to be a little bit of a
duel right there thank you very much
nicole